- de diplomatie des déclarations et un
peu plus de diplomatie de l'action
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
libanais un profond changement le
président français a donné une
conférence de presse après une visite
dans la capitale pérou dévasté par
double exclusion mardi
dans la capitale le bilan encore
provisoire 137 morts et plus de 5000
blessés il a annoncé la tenue d'une
conférence internationale de soutien et
d'appui au liban pour très bientôt
la catastrophe qui a jeté dehors au
moins trois cent mille personnes sans
abri des dizaines
deux personnes sont toujours recherchées
l'aide internationale continue d'affluer
du monde entier à médecins sans
frontières
alerte même face à une possible crise
humanitaire faute à deux médicaments
notamment
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france emmanuel macron
a passé la journée au liban il a tenu
une conférence de presse après s'être
entretenu avec les dirigeants du pays ne
visite qui a été qualifié de positif
selon le président libanais michel aoun
le président français qui a déclaré
qu'il y aurait un avant et un après 4
août à 2020 jour des explosions qui ont
fait apte au moins 137 morts et 5000
blessés plus de 5000 blessés
le président français qui est revenu sur
la colère des libanais contre leur
gouvernement
il assure être du côté du peuple
il annonce même une conférence
internationale de soutien et d'appui à
beyrouth et à la population libanaise
pour mobiliser des financements
internationaux et il promet également de
revenir le 1er septembre prochain dans
les tout prochains jours nous
organiserons le ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères a commencé à
prendre les premiers contacts et a
mobilisé ses équipes
nous organiserons une conférence
internationale de soutien et d'appui à
beyrouth et à la population libanaise
avec pour objectif de mobiliser les
financements internationaux des
européens les américains de tous les
pays de la région et au delà afin de
fournir des médicaments et des soins la
nourriture le nécessaire pour les
logements
nous mettrons aussi en place une
gouvernance claire et transparente pour
que l'ensemble de cette aide
qu'il s'agisse de l'aide française comme
de l'aide internationale soit
directement acheminés aux populations
aux organisations non gouvernementales
aux équipes sur le terrain qui en ont
besoin sans qu' aucune opacité aucun
détournement ne soit possible
les nations unies la banque mondiale
joueront un rôle essentiel en la matière
pour définir clairement les besoins et
permettre à la communauté internationale
comme au peuple libanais d'avoir la
pleine transparence sur l'acheminement
de l'ensemble de cette aide
on va en parler à tout de suite avec nos
invités françois costantini
géopolitologue
morad el hattab écrivain et et
géopolitologue bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
cette visite d' emmanuel macron toute la
journée au liban est ce que vous pensez
qu'à l'heure où justement la solidarité
internationale s'organise
c'est une visite opportune pour je pense
qu'elle s'inscrit dans la ligne en effet
des relations privilégiées entre la
france et le liban elle est un marqueur
en effet ce qu'il faut c'est et c'est
que mène s'arrête pas une pure passe une
communication qu'elles soient suivies
d'effets en effet cette conférence se
tienne dans l'est mais un moment et que
l'aide organisé soit conséquente durable
longue qu'elle s'inscrive peut-être
au-delà de l'aide d'urgence de la
catastrophe et que surtout qu'elle passe
à travers le gouvernement libanais qui
aujourd'hui totalement discrédité par la
population libanaise en général et
beyrouthine en particulier et qu'en
effet on aide les libanais mais pas le
liban officiel en quelque sorte moral
est là t'as pas ce que vous partagez cet
avis également c'était nécessaire de
voir aujourd'hui emmanuel macron dans la
capitale libanaise
après cette effroyable
explosion mardi dernier on va rejoindre
tout à l'heure morad el hattab on a un
petit souci de liaison avec lui on vous
retrouve donc françois costantini on va
poursuivre avec vous en attendant de
rétablir à la liaison avec morad el
hattab justement cette visite elle est
vue d'une certaine manière par la classe
politique française comme
de l'opportunisme aussi de la part du
président français qu'en pensez vous
comme celle que les hommes politiques en
particulier en général mm macro en
particulier sont un calcul médiatique
dans un certain nombre de posture il est
certain qu'il faut pas que cette livi
set lui de quelques heures se limite à
un certain nombre de clichés sinon
l'effet sur les catastrophiques et
fortement déplaisant je crois pour le
peuple libanais qui a pas besoin de ça
donc il faut tout cela soit suivi
d'effets je rappelle qu'il ya quelques
jours avant l'explosion le drame de
beyrouth
jean yves le drian mise affaires
étrangères européennes étaient à pérou
où justement il évoqua lesté de ce qu'il
appelle des réformes de la part du
gouvernement libanais pour que celui ci
bénéficie à nouveau d'une aide
internationale de nouveaux prêts de nous
votons donc il faut de façon conséquent
je pense la communauté internationale se
penche sur le cas du liban sur le cas
particulier dans lequel se trouve le
liban avec notamment la prévenance des
intérêts de viol a des intérêts
régionaux antagonismes dans le liban est
depuis trop longtemps la cible avec
également la prévenance du hezbollah
dont il faut a bien parlé un jour sur le
pays et le fait que en effet le
hezbollah soit aujourd'hui - de façon
indirecte mis en cause dans dans les
malheurs que traverse aujourd'hui le
liban mais le liban n'est pas le seul
même pas seul il ya également un certain
nombre de de danger islamiste qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas sont pas des
moindres et je pense qu'il faudra que la
communauté internationale se penche
définitivement sur sur le liban de façon
durable
on la retrouve et je crois un morad el
hattab qui est maintenant bien en
liaison avec nous un morad el hattab
comment vous vous avez jugé cette visite
dans l'urgence du président français
justement dans l'urgence sauf que
l'urgence pour les libanais et existe
depuis février 2019 c'est pour ça que je
fais assez surpris qu aujourd'hui on est
à évoquer autant la politique intérieure
libanaise
puisque vous savez comme moi que la
priorité d'abord c'est un cheminot
humanitaire la reconstruction dans les
faits actuels du liban ce à peu près 50
milliards de dollars
là on parle de 10 donc on est loin du
compte ce qui me chagrine un peu c'est
que effectivement elle a très bien
rappelé notre ami géopolitique on a un
devoir d'amitié avec le liban on n'a pas
un devoir d'ingérence
et effectivement les postures adoptées
aujourd'hui me gêne énormément je tiens
à rappeler comme que le les le liban
n'est pas une ancienne colonie française
d'un protectorat qui est indépendant et
souverain depuis 1943 et par rapport aux
acteurs régionaux
je vous le dis de boutons blancs ce qui
régleront réellement le problème en
terme de politique intérieure ce sont
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran et en
arrière-plan les états unis et la russie
on essaye et monsieur concertina rappelé
j'ai eu la venue du ministre des
affaires étrangères pas plus tard que
récemment au liban
il n'en est pas sorti des grands
résultats et puis par ailleurs il ya un
point qui est très important on nous
parle d'une explosion or personne a
déterminé à ce jour si c'était une
explosion ou un attentat en france a
cost at il dit sur l'ingérence votre
point de vue le liban depuis trop
longtemps depuis pratiquement comme l'a
rappelé monsieur adam 1943 il était le
sujet des ingérences notamment la ligue
arabe la présence des palestiniens qui a
été une meurtrissure pour le liban qui
est à l'origine de la guerre ensuite le
jeu israélien la présence de la syrie et
la tutelle syrienne pendant 15 ans et
puis en suisse est ce de sortie de la
syrie en 2005 avec un en fait en toile
de fond un renforcement au final du rôle
du hezbollah il se lie banques on a
utilisé un peu comme un appât dans la
bouche de la syrie comme carotte et un
bâton à l'égard de la syrie les états
unis il faut pas l'oublier en 76 ont
fait rentrer la syrie au liban et en
2005 pascal rentrée depuis dans leurs
plans le monde est de sortir donc il
voit il faudra qu'un jour
s'interroge sur l'ensemble des
ingérences et qu'on ne trahisse de façon
durable le lit blanc au plan régional
parce que je pense que un pays comme le
liban c'est à la fois un pays qu'on dit
trop souvent fragile mais c'est un pays
également prometteur avec cette
cohabitation paritaire de l'islam et de
la chrétienté au liban dans le monde
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui je pense c'est
plutôt ça qu'on devrait protéger et
essai c'est en effet les jeunes gens
chaque seigneur qui met aujourd'hui en
péril le modèle libanais sans
l'ingérence je reprends un peu les
termes de morale à la table je pense
qu'il vous allusion à la visite des
mayas le maquereau et l'ingérence
française
mais si vous permettez de quelque chose
de vrai et là on ne prête à sourire
c'est la fameuse promesse de saint-louis
bon lorsqu'il parle du pacte entre
l'islam et le christianisme
mais là où je viens je veux ajouter aux
propos il a effectivement tout à fait
raison le liban est aujourd'hui le pays
qui compte au niveau mondial le plus
grand nombre de réfugiés par rapport à
sa population
donc effectivement à sa cause problème
on l'a peu près de deux millions de
réfugiés syriens et palestiniens sur le
sol libanais il faudra bien sûr régler
cette solution mais je tiens quand même
à rappeler que le libor dans sa
structure aujourd'hui est un casino
il importe 80% de ses biens il faut
savoir que justement dans le cadre d'une
reconstruction du liban
il faudra peut-être réfléchir aussi à
une auto gérance libanaise enfin
l'autosuffisance libanaise en termes
d'agriculture d'industrie
ça peut pas rester une banque offshore à
ces nouvelles rappellent que la
destruction justement du port c'est la
destruction de 60% en tout cas du
transit d'importation concernant le
liban françois constantine et si vous
voulez bien répondre sur l' ingérence
présumée française au liban aujourd'hui
c'est avec cette visite des manuels
macron je pense que si il ya eu
ingérence qui a été à mon avis la plus
douce et la plus acceptable
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
gérance française parce que ça a été mon
service et c'était pas une simple
protocol ans était pas un pro tétouan
c'était un mandat en fait c'était un
mandat qui était donné par le site et
des nations pour amener le liban
et moi moi je la fis en main on peut me
contredire j'ai fait une thèse dessus
j'avais quand même que les années 1920
1940 trois ont été pour moi des années
de bonheur pour le liban parce que la
france il ya construit comme
d'institutions yann et la démocratie il
ya un et l'égalité entre toutes les
communautés je rappelle que avant les
chrétiens vivaient dans un état
d'infériorité dans la région par rapport
à l'islam politique
ils sont sortis la dhimmitude il ya une
parité également entre entre entre
chrétiens et musulmans alors le système
confessionnel il peut être critiquable
je suis tout à fait d'accord là dessus
moi je suis pour un confessionnalisme
rationaliser serre que il doit s'arrêter
à l'équilbre au sein de l'état mais au
niveau la population on doit recruter de
façon sûre le mérite des fonctionnaires
et non pas en fonction de deux critères
confessionnels en effet il faudra
rationaliser le confessionnalisme à mon
autre laïcisé certains espaces il n'est
pas normal par exemple que des libanais
des deux confessions différentes
aie aie se marier à chypre mais monsieur
a tout à fait raison lorsqu'il parle de
toute suffisance le liban pour moi avec
la plaine de la békaa est largement
autosuffisante en agroalimentaire il
peut même exporter il a en effet une des
plaines et les plus fertiles du proche
orient
c'est un état qui a tout les vélleités
en effet pour être autosuffisants et
pour exporter au plan alimentaire mais
ça c'est un problème général vous savez
de conception des échanges mondiaux
globaux et le fait que aujourd'hui on
soit réticent à tout idée d'un
protectionnisme intelligent rationaliser
qui permettrait de revenir à un certain
modèle modèle autocentré et c'est en
effet c'est également la neutralisation
du blanc parce que ce liban trop ouvert
c'est l'extérieur des dépendants en
effet la tomme extérieur on voit ce que
ça donne aujourd'hui et il faut pour moi
que le peuple le développement se fasse
au service du peuple libanais alors vous
parliez tout à l'heure du hezbollah d' 2
et justement emmanuel macron lui il a
tenté de parler en tout cas de lancer un
message à toutes les forces politiques
aux dirigeants libanais la balle est
dans le camp c'est ce cas elle dit en
fait les manuels macron qu effectivement
la france peut appuyer une certaine
solidarité internationale mais la balle
est vraiment dans le camp des dirigeants
libanais morad el hattab est ce que
véritablement il ya un pacte politique
possible au liban c'est ce que demande
emmanuel macron avec la situation
actuelle les relations rôle c'est entre
les autorités le hezbollah tout ça est
très compliqué oui d'abord d'abord il
est bon de rappeler que au liban il ya
eu des élections et les libanais ont
choisi parce que on fait comme si
sorti du chapeau des mouvements
politiques non c'est le choix du peuple
libanais les libanais sont pas venus
contester nos élus récent avec 60% de
taux d'abstention bon parce que ça je
tiens à le rappeler qu néanmoins d'eux
est mort effectivement la présence du
hezbollah est une présence forte
importante au liban elle fait le jeu
dans le sens où c'est aussi une force
armée bien plus armé que l'armée
légitime d'ibanez donc ça va c'est j'ai
presque envie de dire vous pouvez pas
faire le liban aujourd'hui sans le
hezbollah et puis par ailleurs c'est ce
que je tenais à dire dès le départ c'est
que ceux qui sont les réels levier du
règlement interne au liban sont
effectivement l'iran qui finissent qui
financent à hauteur de 700 millions de
dollars par an le hezbollah et l'arabie
saoudite dans le sens où il faudra
trouver devront s'asseoir à une table et
trouver un compromis où il y aura en
arrière-plan les états unis et la russie
aujourd'hui la france c'est un voeu
pieux que qu'annonce emmanuel macron et
je vous dis encore une fois même sur le
plan financier
ça ne répond pas aux attentes de la
reconstruction du liban ça c'est un
problème
et puis aussi injuste une chose que je
voulais rajouter notre ami a très
justement justifie la plaine des cas il
faut ajouter aussi un autre point
essentiel
c'est la découverte de gisements gaziers
sur les côtes libanaises
il permettra aussi une autosuffisance
sur le plan énergétique parce qu'on
n'arrête pas de parler dé prendre des
cités et autres le liban peut régler
aussi ce problème
françois costantini on va conclure
justement le cette solidarité
internationale qui s'exprime on voit des
acteurs qui sont mauvaises relations
normalement avec le liban c'est le cas
d'israël c'est le cas de l'iran exprimer
leur solidarité est ce que finalement il
ya quelque chose qui peut sortir de ce
drame quelque chose de positif qui peut
permettre justement à la région de deux
de sortir de cet imbroglio géopolitique
dans lequel il est plat est ce qui
chacun était bonne foi josé dire si
l'iran au delà de ces messages de
soutien arrêtez peut-être de considérer
le liban comme ça pointe avancée dans
ses intérêts dans lequel le hezbollah
si israël en effet arrêté un peu son jeu
cynique montrant qu'elle n'a jamais mais
le système anti confessionnel au liban
et qu'elle verrait bien le liban est une
terre d'implantation des palestiniens ce
qui ce qui ne saurait être les cas ce
qui est rejeté par la quasi totalité de
la population libanaise et bien
peut-être qu on avancerait mais encore
faudrait-il que tous ces acteurs
régionaux notamment notamment ceux que
vous avez cités soit bonne foi et arrête
de faire du liban le champ clos de l'or
de leur antagonisme réciproque pour vous
à mourad est elle à table
ben moi je dis que bénéficie de toutes
les ressources humaines et on le voit
aussi énergétiques et agricoles pour
redevenir commune la cité tout à l'heure
entre 1922 34 ce qu'on appelait la
suisse du moyen-orient merci merci à
vous françois constantine et je rappelle
que vous êtes géopolitologue morad el
hattab écrivain et géopolitologue à
beyrouth
les recherches continuent en tout cas
pour retrouver d'éventuels survivants
une opération de sauvetage qui se
déroule parallèlement au nettoyage de la
ville le pays et la population se
mobilise pour tenter de reloger à un
maximum de personnes parmi les trois
cent mille habitants aujourd'hui sans
abri ont fait le point avec at t aux
combes et maxime buathier on verra t-on
encore des scènes comme celle là si cet
homme sorti des décombres ir vivra le
sort de dizaines de personnes toujours
disparues inquiète les recherches pour
trouver des survivants dans les ruines
de beyrouth se poursuivre
le colonel vincent tessier du
détachement de la sécurité civile
envoyés par la france au liban se veut
confiant devant emmanuel macron il
estime que les chances de retrouver les
disparus sont toujours importantes
donc on recherche sept ou huit
personnels disparus qui seraient coincés
dans une salle de commande enterré par
l'explosion dans cette direction à
environ 400 mètres
avec les renseignements que nous allons
sans confirmer la présence de personnes
dans une salle fermée qui a été enseveli
on pense qu'être bon espoir de retrouver
des victimes des personnes vivantes
parallèlement le nettoyage de la ville
commence si l'armée envoie des bulldozer
pour déblayer les routes c'est les
services municipaux de la capitale
s'organiser pour le nettoiement des
actions bien souvent réalisées avec
l'aide des habitants au représentant le
syndicat des municipalités de la
banlieue sud ainsi que ces municipalités
les oeuvres ont actuellement pour
retirer les décombres et nettoyer les
rues si nous avons participé à la lutte
contre les incendies ou un transport des
blessés vers les hôpitaux de la banlieue
sud et nous avons lancé une initiative
pour héberger les personnes des
quartiers touchés afin que nous
puissions les recevoir dans nos maisons
aujourd'hui en optimisant les capacités
disponibles
toute l'équipe des pompiers de la
banlieue sud en coordination avec la
brigade des pompiers de la ville de
beyrouth et toutes les personnes
concernées sur le terrain travaillent à
nettoyer la ville autant que possible
machine l'objectif est vital relogés au
maximum les 300 mille personnes qui
selon le gouverneur de la ville sont
aujourd'hui sans abri
et il ya urgence selon le franco
libanais mego terzian président de
médecins sans frontières
notre priorité dans les jours à venir
sera le suivi de ces populations
déplacées
l'autre priorité seront les malades
chroniques ceux atteints de cancer du
vih ou des maladies respiratoires comme
l'asthme avec le risque de rupture de
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
nous avons par ailleurs aussi appris que
des entrepôts de médicaments et de
vaccins situé dans le port de beyrouth
avait été endommagée pour l'air marwan
abou de le gouverneur de beyrouth a
estimé le coût des dommages à plus de 3
milliards de dollars
solidarité avec le peuple libanais c'est
le mot d'ordre en tout cas c'était le
mot d'ordre d'un rassemblement cet après
midi à puteaux en région parisienne une
cérémonie organisée par la municipalité
par des associations locales discours
hymne national libanais marseillaise en
résonnaient dans la ville en présence
d'une centaine de personnes on va
écouter quelques témoignages au micro de
renault parquet si nos amis libanais
souffrent nous sommes là nous sommes là
présent mais ça vraiment c'est trop
vraiment trop trop brutale est on est on
est vraiment sonné et pour nos amis
libanais voilà le gouvernement libanais
a prouvé qu'il était incapable
on connaît et qu'il était impossible de
lui faire confiance donc surtout s'il ya
des aides internationales doute d'où
qu'elle vienne soit qu'elles sont en
sous la forme de aide aide matérielle
mais tous mellal tout ce qui est
financier qu'ils n'aillent pas dans les
poches de nous de nos gouverneurs de
notre gouvernement parce que le liban a
perdu totalement confiance en son
gouvernement
on en vient maintenant à cette prise
d'otage
qui est en cours au havre dans une
agence bancaire du centre-ville trois
personnes seraient retenus par un homme
armé selon france bleu normandie
trois personnes auraient déjà été
libérés plus tôt dans l'après midi selon
une source policière le raid est sur
place aucun blessé ne seraient pas
signalés à le preneur d'otages âgé de 34
ans très connu des services de police
pour des antécédents psychiatriques
selon une source proche de l'enquêté
citée par la fp le ministre de
l'intérieur géré halderman a annoncé sur
les réseaux sociaux suivre la situation
avec attention
on en vient à la pandémie la norvège qui
repasse à la france en zone rouge une
quarantaine de dix jours qui sera
obligatoire pour tous les voyageurs
provenant de l'hexagone en cause ce
chiffre 1604 contamination à la copie de
19 ans 24 heures un nombre à deux
nouveaux cas au plus haut depuis à la
fin mai huit décès supplémentaires et le
nombre de cas graves en réanimation est
reparti à la hausse avec 390 admission
et c'est dans ce contexte de rebond que
le masque en extérieur pourrait se
généraliser à travers tout le territoire
à toulouse par exemple son port est
obligatoire dans certaines zones très
fréquentées entre midi et trois heures
du matin une décision qui pourrait
s'étendre à toute la ville si les règles
ne sont pas respectées
c'est un test
si les gens y réponde et qu'on se rende
compte que le nombre de cas positifs se
freine freine voir se stabilisent voire
se réduit entre rhône ça voudra dire que
là encore une fois de plus ensemble
en citoyen responsable on aura répondu
légitimement à cette attente
si ça suffit pas et si on continue à
faire n'importe quoi
malheureusement il n'y aura pas d'autre
solution puisque au delà de ça c'est ce
qu'a d'ailleurs posé aujourd'hui hier je
crois le conseil scientifique est qu un
point d'interrogation
on va probablement vers une deuxième
vague et pourquoi pas à nouveau un
confinement ce qui serait terrible
terrible pour les personnes terrible
pour la société est terrible pour la
période hivernale qui va arriver donc
c'est un c'est un appel à la citoyenneté
et à la prise de conscience de chacun
oui sortez mais sortez masqué on va
écouter une ride
caselli noah il est chef du service des
urgences à l'hôpital bichat et il
appelle tous les citoyens à respecter
les gestes barrière seule solution pour
lui pour diminuer la transmission de la
maladie
je pense que le conseil scientifique a
été assez clair si nous ne faisons rien
l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague
elle est inéluctable si nous sommes
capables de nous organiser si nous
sommes capables de convaincre nos
concitoyens et de faire appliquer des
mesures de prévention qui comprennent
bien sûr le port des masques à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur dans des
secteurs où il ya une densité de
personnes importantes là nous pourrons
réduire l'importance de la vague dans
nos régions dont nos villes
diminuer le nombre de nouvelles
infections diminuer la transmission de
la maladie et nous pourrons donc réduire
le nombre de décès de besoin de lits en
hospitalisation est en réanimation et
dans l'actualité africaine alpha condé
qui déclarent prendre acte de la
décision de son parti présidentiel verts
pg le rassemblement du peuple de guinée
qui l'a désigné candidat à la
présidentielle d'octobre
aujourd'hui à l'issue à une convention
électorale mais sa possible candidature
est loin de faire l'unanimité au sein de
la population depuis presque un an
une vague de protestations s'est
soulevée contre l'hypothèse d'un
troisième mandat du chef de l'état
sortant le point avec emilie vous gâche
alpha condé l'a plusieurs fois répété
la décision de se porter candidat à la
présidentielle reviendra à son parti
c'est désormais chose faite
réunis depuis mercredi pour désigner
leur candidat
au moins 350 cadres du rpg ont plaidé en
faveur d'un 3e mandat du président
guinéen par soit on a vu que la lgv
annoncé est le meilleur choix
c'est qu'il a fait pendant ces dix ans
pour qu'un paix aucun président à faire
dans ce pèlerinage
alpha condé ce n'est pas seulement le
choix de progrès et on lave
l'éventualité de ce troisième mandat
d'alpha condé créé en revanche la
division au sein de la population
depuis presque un an s'est formé le fn
décès qu'on national pour la défense de
la constitution composé des principaux
partis d'opposition et d'organisations
de la société civile
le fn décès s'oppose à ce qu'il soit à
nouveau président plusieurs fois réprimé
les rassemblements de l'opposition ont
fait des dizaines de morts parmi les
manifestants
un collectif d'opposants guinée en a
même déposé plainte en france contre
alpha condé certains de ses proches
qu'il y a quelques jours
ensemble ils l'accusent de corruption
trafic d'influencé blanchiment
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver en
direct dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]